you guys know elixion right i want to
death he is the wonderful person that
has animated so many beloved animations
on my channel
i hate everything you stand for and he's
been helping me out by editing my videos
lately breakfast
duh well he in his spare time decided to
make me
an entire game for my birthday and
that's amazing by itself but also it
came with this lovely note
hi mark i just wanted to say thank you
thank you for everything you've
completely changed my life for the
better
you gave me so many opportunities and i
am so grateful and happy to be working
alongside such an incredible person
i wanted to show my appreciation for you
and i feel like i don't do that enough
i decided that for your birthday i would
make you this small
little game i had very little time to
work on this i started on june 3rd i
believe
so it is far from perfect but i hope you
can still enjoy it
happy late birthday and once again thank
you for everything
sincerely luis lisian disclaimer i did
not make any of the pretty assets
so number one i'm
freaking honored that anyone would make
a game for me uh but also he's not late
i am late it is it is july 31st and he
gave me this game like uh
only a couple days after my birthday as
far as i believe
so i'm gonna play this we're gonna do
this
and it's gonna be cool no wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute damian huh
okay all right oh no
you did not oh
no you did not hang on a second here
it looks familiar
i get i get the disclaimer for not
making any of the pretty assets now
all right okay cool i love it
i mean i love it just because it is
damien and i love that
[Music]
if you haven't seen damien yet there's
probably going to be spoilers so go
check it out
on my channel oh what the hell is going
on here
what the hell is this
wow
hell yeah pick up a log and place it on
the stump oh hey
[Music]
celine
celine hey you're not looking at me
why aren't you looking at your bag
celine
celine all right fine then
all right pop love it
cool great love it all right
okay i see how this is i see okay
i love how snappy everything is ah man
all these games that are all
loosey-goosey and this one's snappy
so fresh uh a real talented game
designer this one
i love the ambiance yeah who i think i
love about anywhere indie games
maybe it's the horror game i don't know
it's the ambiance look at the
actually look at this i'm not even
joking about this this looks really good
oh oops there i am
don't slam the door damien tell me
what the i saw a flower today
flowers shouldn't be long now before
yeah if you haven't seen damian or
there's still a few more weeks of winter
left and that flower will die
cold or
that either way winter can't last
forever celine
with any luck we'll be able to get out
of this cabin soon luck
doesn't keep the fire going luck won't
change the weather
and luck definitely won't put food on
the table
well i mean if you think about it you
probably do need some luck in finding
something to eat
in the middle of winter out in snow
good luck whatever try not to burn the
cabin down while i'm out
aye aye captain did you really see a
flower
yes a little pink one
probably dead by now uh get some sleep
you look tired no no one's allowed
to say i'm tired no one ever you're
starting to sound like mom
judging this down like mom starting to
sound like mom
okay place 10 firewood in fireplace you
got it can i get my axe what do we got
here
where'd this mirror come from i don't
remember that being there
hmm i'm not thirsty you don't know that
you don't know that i'm not i'm not
tired
yeah definitely okay okay
what thrilling gameplay stunning
graphics i gotta say
it really is the pacing is
maybe i'm tell what maybe i am thirsty
you know you know me
i'm pretty thirsty can i leave no okay
all right go to bed
lay my head to rest oh hello
what the hell okay well this is new
okay
oh what did i die wait did i die somehow
oh i was probably taking too much time
i was just like everything looks so cool
okay all right get to the light i do
understand i'm gonna get to the light
right here
oh i see
now okay that's pretty that's pretty
whoa hey there hi
what the hell
okay oh hi
ah you
you silly silly silly
you silly silly silly silly silly silly
well you don't die easily do you i'll
tell you what dies easily
me in a horror game what
hello hello you want
two people so many people
who's there i can't believe how quickly
you put this together
like this is really good yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah take that woof dash hey
yeah okay shift the sprint i'm running
back to the cabin
i should investigate the voices first
yeah i don't know about that
maybe i mean i'm not want to do that
hello
i love this because it's like an
extended version
oh wait let me check this way first
no no i'm gonna check this way
hello
time for firewood hello
here's damie over here
oh hi oh
all right let's move on cool all right
yum well good thing i collected the
weird mannequin heads
oh he's like that where is this leading
us
there's a lot of environment here
there's a lot of really good stuff how
did he make this so quickly do i got a
leap over that
i took a running jump i can't jump so i
guess
do i get to push this wow really
oh this is a treat that can't be beat
man these are some strong vines fungus
look at those physics it's a thing of
beauty
any more manu can heads hello
manukins any more manukin heads
yeah i love the i love the speed of this
axe like it's
it's quite satisfying i got i gotta
admit even though things are obviously
simplistic in this game and
it's it's almost a meme for me to be
appreciative of the finer details of it
i i'm appreciating the finer details of
it like it's it's not often that things
are snappy like that i feel like there's
gonna be some heads here
it's a weird thing to say yeah if
there's like skulls in the next section
i i'm gonna have to replay through the
game
i just stand be good
oh hi hey how you doing oh what's up
whoa right
cool good for you
congratulations on whatever that was
good show you know what's fascinating
about this is
it is like an extended cut because i
actually wrote more stuff to be
here and yet
and yet here it is
all coming out of lexian's imagination
collect wood you got it hey
hey what what what
what what
okay i guess i'll collect wood then
guys celene there's some weird stuff
happening
is your text in the top corner of your
head
weird mine's a little acting funny
okay anyway celine i don't know
all right i'm coming in hello
hey all right cool
don't slam the door don't slam the door
dangerous
yeah okay yeah sure
i saw a flower today shouldn't be long
now before
spring are there still a few more weeks
of winter left and that flower will die
what are you muttering about i heard
a voice today ghost demon voice
zombie as clear as i'm hearing you
there's no one else in these woods
damien but it sounded far away
i i should have followed the voice but
it trailed off
and i had to get back with firewood
but we have plenty of fire
damian there is no one else in these
woods if there were
i'm sure i would have run into them by
now i'm sure you would have run into
them by now you need to sleep
are you staying up while i'm out what no
i'm fine i'm not even tired
what about you are you tired you're
always awake by the time i get back i'm
not a growing boy like you little
brother
oh please you're older by 10 minutes
which is just long enough for me to be
in charge so
shut up and go to bed that doesn't make
you in charge how does that make you the
boss of me
just just be careful
i don't know maybe i'm crazy but
whatever i heard out in those woods it
didn't sound too friendly
uh just be careful you mean the thing
that charged my face
i can take care of myself don't slam the
door you can't do it you always need to
be right
sometimes i'm right sometimes i know
things
sometimes i know things most times i
don't know things
most times i don't ooh that's a lot of
firewood
oh anyway am i thirsty now
am i thirsty i might be thirsty i'm not
thirsty
hello you sure
[Music]
oh
okay okay
hello what
you know what's fascinating is like this
this makes me realize i could have gone
so much farther with the horror
in damien which is what i wanted to do
but i had such a limited amount of
experience with the medium and a lot of
things but this is cool
hi yes hello i'm here can i help you
[Music]
someone's a grouchy gus
i don't wanna no i'm good i don't need
to check the mirror the mirrors
that's fine all we're talking about
looks good from where i'm standing
all mirroresque and uh full of
reflections
and uh i just need to check mirror i
don't know
why can't i see myself
hello
that's cool this is really cool
it's time to wake up
i love this that's my favorite moment of
the whole little goddamn thing
i love this oh man
is that you
i want wait did he find the music
did he find what music this was because
he did didn't he
okay actually i've i've turned around so
much i have no idea where
forward is celine oh wait no that's the
point
oh that's so cool
clean oh this is so cool
am i going the right way am i going the
wrong is there
oh it's so cool oh it's so cool oh he's
done
a good job with this oh it's so cool
oh
whoa oh that's not good
oh oh oh oh that's not good
oh oh should i should i i'm gonna fight
you
okay maybe not fight maybe fight not
maybe not the fight maybe don't do the
fighting thing
fighting not the best idea okay
here we go okay okay keep moving don't
look back
why do i always look back in horror
games i i just don't whoa
okay closer than i thought okay all
right cool i bet there's a pile of heads
somewhere in here
i bet there is i bet there is
oh i bet i missed it oh i probably
missed it
oh i don't know what the pile of heads
is for if it's for
anything actually you still back there
oh you so slow you so slow you loser
loser big lose big loser
okay i guess i gotta keep going then
hey
[Music]
that's so cool that's so well done
i've i mean i totally screwed it up but
man
i love that we get a good view of that
monster's taint on the way up but
man okay i think i gotta like follow the
path
or something okay
oh okay i might be goofing something
a little bit i think
get with me for just a second because
i'm quite dumb
straight for it no moving
oh there we go okay made it
oh god
it's really well done it's well done
this is well done
i mean it's obviously like done quickly
but man it's done well oh oh no
not this again no not this again
oh no
oh hi
hey how are you doing damien you are a
hard man
oh that's so
[Music]
dull that's so good
that's just so
goddamn good that's so gosh darn
it's so good i it literally
like that's just
i i love it
thank you thank you very much for making
this
i i i'm just like
i'm so tickled that i'm chuffed
damien was such a passion project and if
i could go back and take what i've
learned now like
i would enhance it in the way that
lixian has enhanced it but now you know
you can get a little taste of
some more horror to it that's so cool i
don't know what this
the heads were about if that was an
easter egg or if that was just a one-off
thing
man i loved it
i really loved it i uh i want to give
i want to give a thank you to lexian
right now you gave me a nice thank you
at the beginning of this so i'm going to
give you a nice thank you at the end of
it well
i mean you can decide if it's nice or
not once i'm done with it but
first and foremost i have met a lot of
talented hard-working people in my time
on youtube
not one of them compares to the
dedication
the skill like the commitment and just
the sheer
speed at which you work it's stunning i
have no idea how you do it
you have been helping me with my channel
since almost the very beginning the
first animation that i ever saw this is
for people at home the first animation
that i ever saw
someone make about my videos was
lixian's animation it blew me away
i had no idea that could even happen i
didn't even know what like the format
was
but lixian made it i reached out to him
and ever since then he has made
landmark animations on my channel
they're amazing they are part of the
reason
why i'm able to be here today
make no mistake i would not be here
my channel would not be nearly as big i
would not have nearly as much success
without you lixie you are an integral
part of this
community you're an integral part of
this channel and i am so grateful
that you are not only helping me with
editing videos and doing them better
than i
ever could but also taking the time out
of your day to make
this just for my birthday and to kick up
a project that i
like that i was very passionate about
and take it to like another level that's
stunning that's so crazy like damn you
for being so talented i just
you know i am
i'm grateful i'm really
really truly grateful and i never want
to take
your talent for granted
i never want to take your time for
granted i never want to take anything
that you offer to me for granted because
you deserve all the praise in the world
for doing what you do and if everyone at
home watching
doesn't know lixian also makes videos
on his channel like cntv i i've been
starting linking
uh his channel in every video that he
edits for me which is the majority of
them now
and um if you guys want to see
who lixian is what kind of stuff he
makes and just like
follow him in his own capacity go in the
description click
on that link to go to elixiontv and
check out his stuff and please subscribe
to him he's amazing and lexian
how dare you improve on something that i
thought couldn't be improved upon
how dare you how
dare you but sincerely thank you
i'm very very fortunate to have you on
my team
and i cannot thank you enough
so thank you and thank you everybody for
watching
at home and uh just thank the world
thanks
oxygen oxygen is great everyone needs to
thank oxygen we wouldn't be here without
oxygen
so thank you if you want to see the
original damien you can check it out uh
in the uh in the description i'll link
it
and uh yeah just this is so cool
this is so cool i can't express how cool
this is
but thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye